[Música]
histórico encuentro el papá francisco se
reunió con el principal clérigo chiíta
de irak el ayatolá ali al sistaní
durante el segundo día de su visita por
el país con un llamado a la coexistencia
entre religiones el sumo pontífice
realiza hoy también una visita a la
ciudad de un lugar donde se cree nació
el profeta abraham considerado padre de
los tres monoteísmos cristianismo
judaísmo e islam
el senado estadounidense logró
desbloquear las negociaciones con miras
a la aprobación del plan de alivio de
1.9 billones de dólares propuesto por
joe biden los demócratas tuvieron que
reducir el monto de los subsidios por
desempleo que regirán hasta el 6 de
septiembre para poder darle continuidad
a los diálogos que siguen esta madrugada
fuertes enfrentamientos entre civiles y
uniformados se presentaron la noche de
este viernes en la capital de paraguay
los manifestantes se lanzaron a las
calles para protestar contra el manejo
del gobierno a la emergencia sanitaria
generada por el joven 19 una situación
que provocó la renuncia del ministro de
salud
buenos días y bienvenidos a una nueva
emisión de noticias de france 24 los
saluda andrés besa muñoz continúa la
gira del papá francisco en irak durante
este segundo día de visita al sumo
pontífice se reunió con el principal
clérigo chiíta de irak el ayatolá ali al
sistaní un encuentro considerado como
histórico en las relaciones entre el
islam y el vaticano se conoció que
durante la reunión que se realizó sin la
presencia de los medios
ambos líderes insistieron en la
coexistencia entre religiones en un país
marcado por el sectarismo y la violencia
francisco también realizada hoy una
visita a la ciudad de un lugar donde se
cree nació el profeta abraham
considerado padre de los tres
monoteísmos cristianismo judaísmo e
islam condenó toda violencia cometida en
nombre de dios calificándola como la
grave blasfemia
desde un nuestra enviada especial a ir a
catalina gómez ángel tiene los detalles
de esta segunda jornada de visita del
papa- francisco
el papá empezó el día con una visita
considerada histórica mira cuando viajó
a la ciudad de nayaf y caminó por esas
callejuelas a encontrarse con raya toda
la visitan y la figura del chiísmo más
importante también la figura religiosa
más importante él ha apoyado con gracia
en el 2005 también fue a quien dio esa
factura en el 2014 cuando hiciste la
toma donde en tercera parte del país
para que los jóvenes y los hombres de
este país se juntaron con las fuerzas
armadas y lucharán para detener el
avance del estado islámico el papa
sostuvo una conversación en la colaron
de proteger a los cristianos de esta
nación y luego se dirigió hasta aquí
hasta donde nos encontramos aún en el
sur de irak que es la cuna de abraham el
padre de las tres religiones del libro y
se reunió con líderes de las etnias y de
las religiones de esta parte del país
bienvenido y
desde bagdad en un mensaje de
fraternidad y convivencia muy simbólico
en el cual les pide también a ellos que
ayuden a proteger a estas minorías que
viven en el país
la llave es el centro del chiísmo en
irak en esta ciudad al sur de bagdad
reside la casa como se conoce el
seminario chiíta cuyo mayor
representante es el ayatolá ali al
sistaní la visita a nayaf es un gesto de
reconocimiento a los chiítas secta
minoritaria del islam que predomina en
irán pero también un mensaje para la
unidad de irak y la convivencia pacífica
entre sus etnias y religiones informe de
catalina gómez ángel y ricardo garcía
vilanova
todos los caminos en la llave conducen a
la mezquita del imam ali el yerno del
profeta mahoma y con quien inicia el
chiísmo la rama del islam mayoritaria en
irak
el alba va esta iniciativa del papá de
visitar al ayatolá alí sistaní será un
camino para acercar el entendimiento
sobre el islám del slam este santuario
es el lugar más sagrado para los chiítas
después de la meca y medina en arabia
saudita hasta que llegan millones de
peregrinos cada año y en estos
corredores se educan los clérigos bajo
la tutela de los grandes ayatolás
incluido alí sistaní la máxima figura
religiosa de nayaf y de irak que por su
avanzada edad se le ve muy poco en la
ciudad
el papa visitará asisten y en nayaf
ambos comparten los mismos principios el
amor la paz el respeto a la humanidad el
respeto a ellos mismos externamente
esta librería tuvo una sección
clandestina durante la dictadura de
sadam husein cuando se libró una campaña
para silenciar a los chiítas
especialmente a la causa o seminario de
nayaf esto llevó a que la ciudad y su
visión del chiísmo fuera atacada por
como el centro de esta rama del islam en
irán donde los clérigos chiítas
gobiernan desde 1979 sidebar alum
considera que los seminarios de nayaf y
com no están en competencia pero si
tienen divisiones intelectuales una de
ellas es sobre la religión el estado
sobre la que la iab defiende su
separación venimos de un periodo en el
que estábamos alejados del mundo
estábamos encerrados aquí ahora esta
visita pondrá el foco en nayaf y el
mundo se preguntará qué significa nada
años atrás el papá se acercó a los
líderes del sunismo la secta mayoritaria
del islam en el mundo en un intento por
establecer un diálogo entre religiones
ahora hace lo mismo con la causa de
nayaf un reconocimiento que muchos
chiítas celebran como un triunfo en irak
el senado estadounidense logró
desbloquear las negociaciones con miras
a la aprobación del plan de alivio de
1.9 billones de dólares propuesto por
joe biden los demócratas tuvieron que
reducir de 400 a 300 dólares semanales
los subsidios por desempleo que regirán
hasta el 6 de septiembre para poder
darle continuidad a los diálogos que se
han extendido hasta esta madrugada los
demócratas esperan que el paquete que
incluye fondos para las vacunas y
suministros médicos pueda aprobarse y
ser firmado por bailén durante los
próximos días
y los demócratas del senado cumplirán
con el plan de rescate estamos unidos en
nuestra creencia sobre lo audaz e
importante que es este proyecto de ley
de alivio por el cob y para las vacunas
para las escuelas para los pequeños
negocios para las familias y para el
pueblo no se equivoquen seguiremos
trabajando hasta que el trabajo esté
hecho
vamos a paraguay porque las calles de la
capital fueron el escenario de
enfrentamientos entre la policía y
cientos de manifestantes durante la
noche de este viernes los uniformados
dispararon balas de goma y gases
lacrimógenos contra los ciudadanos que
llegaron hasta el edificio del congreso
para protestar contra el manejo que el
gobierno le ha dado a la emergencia
sanitaria generada por el joven 19 en
medio del aumento en el número de
contagios y hospitalizaciones una
situación que provocó la renuncia del
ministro de salud un día después de que
los legisladores pidieran su destitución
yo dejé el cargo del ministerio de salud
pública a los efectos de que realmente
se pueda generar esta paz que
necesitamos para poder enfrentar este
desafío y si esta decisión contribuye a
ello creo que es importante y que
constituye una decisión de estado por
encima de los intereses o de los
análisis personales que se puede hacer
pasamos a francia el gobierno endureció
las restricciones en las regiones
afectadas por los altos índices de
contagio en un nuevo intento por evitar
un nuevo confinamiento nacional a partir
de este sábado la región del norte pasó
en cullen se une a otras como dunkerque
o la costa azul con confinamiento los
fines de semana
con una tasa de infección de casi el
doble del promedio nacional la región
alrededor de la ciudad de cali con costa
al canal de la mancha recibe el golpe de
nuevas restricciones al igual que la
vecina dunkerque o la costa azul 1,4
millones de residentes estarán
confinados en el norte los siguientes
cuatro fines de semana
no es normal estamos en el norte en
dunkerque tienen dos fines de semana
nosotros más hay kilómetros de espacio
podemos pasear sin rozar nos unos a
otros no hay al gentío de parís como se
ve en el canal san martín abro sábados y
domingos esta es la fiesta de las
abuelas y esperaba poder trabajar mucho
a excepción de los supermercados los
centros comerciales de más de 5.000
metros cuadrados quedan cerrados hoy
francia tiene 23 departamentos en alto
riesgo luego de que el primer ministro
incluyera a en off y altos alpes en la
lista
allí los puntos de encuentro pueden ser
prohibidos y de hecho ciudades como
parís y burdeos no permitirán consumir
alcohol en exterior en los centros
urbanos de este modo con confinamientos
cortos y variables según región francia
intenta evitar un bloqueo general a la
vez que intensifica su vacunación
y si me voy
a mediados de mayo habremos vacunado a
cerca de 20 millones de personas es
decir a casi todas las personas de 50
años o más que deseen vacunarse y para
el verano habremos recibido dosis
suficientes para 30 millones de personas
dos tercios de los mayores de 18 años de
la publicación en marzo los
farmacéuticos ya podrán suministrar
dosis para entonces el gobierno ha
confirmado que recibirá el triple de
dosis ergo más de 20 millones de vacunas
y antes de despedirnos los invitamos a
visitar nuestra página web www punto
frente 4 punto com en portada detalles
de la vacunación en eeuu con 2 millones
de dosis al día también la alerta de la
web s sobre la gravedad del avance de la
pandemia en brásil
de esta manera despedimos este
informativo de france 24 continúen con
nosotros
[Música]